OLIVIA: We are incredibly
lucky and delighted to have
two of the best,
and most well-known,
restaurateurs and chefs
proprietors in San
Francisco in the Bay Area,
Chef Hiro Sone and Chef Lissa
Doumani.
Good friends of
mine, but the people
who put Napa on the map
with food, many years ago
with their restaurant Terra.
And then they opened
Ame, in the city.
And then there is something
they may reveal later
about another restaurant.
But those two are perennial
Michelin star restaurants.
In 2003 you were named
James Beard best chef?
HIRO SONE: Yes, Best
Chef California.
SPEAKER: Best Chef California.
And so, very early on
Terra was the place
I went to for astonishingly
beautiful food that
was so fresh and so local.
I'll let them talk about
their romance later,
but they met at
Spago in Los Angeles.
And so it was a
trans-Pacific romance,
and all sorts of things right?
LISSA DOUMANI: A language issue.
OLIVIA: A language issue.
HIRO SONE: Still.
OLIVIA: Still.
[LAUGHTER]
LISSA DOUMANI: Before
It really was one,
now it's because we're married.
[LAUGHTER]
OLIVIA: Intense-- that gets
more intense, but I-- OK.
I will leave that--
HIRO SONE: Yeah, we
try not to go there.
[LAUGHTER]
OLIVIA: So, they
have, of course,
their beautiful
cookbook "Terra,"
but this new book
is a departure.
The official title, "A Visual
Guide to Sushi-Making at Home."
LISSA DOUMANI: It's
a really long name.
OLIVIA: And I think it comes
from very deep within them.
It's been described
as autobiographical.
And I think it is
what they love to do,
and what they love together,
and probably love to eat.
And the book is
incredibly accessible
for the American home cook.
And so, although I don't
think any of the restaurants
will officially have
sushi on the menu,
we are especially lucky
that they are telling us
how to do it and
do it perfectly.
So, welcome.
Welcome to Google, both of you.
LISSA DOUMANI: Thank you.
HIRO SONE: Thank you very much.
OLIVIA: And you're going to do
a couple of things mix-and-match
from the book.
So, I'm going to
leave it to you.
Tell us what you're going to do.
HIRO SONE: Good afternoon.
LISSA DOUMANI: Ok, first I'm
going to explain something
because the first question when
we came in is, Olivia asked us,
would we like chefs' jackets.
And usually when we
do cooking classes,
we do wear chefs' jackets.
But this is sushi from home.
We do not wear them at home.
[LAUGHTER]
So we thought for
this we should be
just like when we would be
when we're actually making it.
And yes, he usually
leaves wherever
I am and goes someplace else.
So, that's why we don't
look like we usually
do when we do this.
You can talk now.
HIRO SONE: OK.
So we have a limited
time and first we're
going to start with
making sushi rice,
basically using Japanese rice.
There are instructions
in our book, how to wash
and how to cook.
So, steaming hot
Japanese rice here.
And we're going
to put it in now.
LISSA DOUMANI: Ok, at home
we don't have one of these.
I've never seen one.
HIRO SONE: You don't
have to use this.
LISSA DOUMANI: So
don't try to find that.
It looks like what you put your
personal things in the laundry
with.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
HIRO SONE: Yeah.
And this special vessel is
called hangiri in Japanese.
Basically, cutting
rice, it means cut rice.
LISSA DOUMANI:
Does this say fan?
HIRO SONE: No, it says Google.
[LAUGHTER]
LISSA DOUMANI: Ok,
that's not kawaii.
HIRO SONE: So this is sushizu.
Also in the book, how to make.
Basically vinegar,
Japanese vinegar,
rice vinegar, sugar and kelp.
Boil it together and
salt, and strain the kelp.
There's some remaining in
here but, it's good for you.
So just--
LISSA DOUMANI: It adds texture.
HIRO SONE: It has
to be hot rice.
OLIVIA: Is that a special
fan people have to have?
LISSA DOUMANI: You have
to go make this fan.
[LAUGHTER]
You don't have to
have it say Google,
it can say anything you'd like.
HIRO SONE: So basically, we
don't want to smash rice.
We're going to cut
rice and make it flaky.
First, kind of looks like
smashing, but touching rice.
OLIVIA: And why is it important
to have a chef fan it for you
while you're cutting?
LISSA DOUMANI: It
makes him feel special.
HIRO SONE: You can see
the evaporation here.
If you don't make more
evaporation happening.
Sushi rice gets wet.
So, you want to evaporate excess
water, moisture from the rice.
LISSA DOUMANI:
It'll make it gummy.
HIRO SONE: Also, this
special vessel, it's wood,
so it dissolves
all the steam too.
So, that's going to help absorb.
Yeah.
LISSA DOUMANI: So,
at home, of course,
we actually had one of these.
He lost it.
But, we don't usually, we don't
really-- he's still looking.
We don't really know--
we don't use this.
HIRO SONE: Fan here please.
LISSA DOUMANI: Fan here please.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm not doing my job.
OK.
So we just use a wide
bowl and do this.
And you know that
thing, this thing?
Because when you do
this by yourself,
that's what this feels like.
Because you're trying to
cut the rice and fan it
with the other hand.
Sometimes you just have
to stop, because you
can't chew bubble gum and walk.
HIRO SONE: You can't?
LISSA DOUMANI: Its
like the same problem.
HIRO SONE: So, as you see, you
can see the individual rice
grains.
It's not clumped.
That's what we want.
And we want to fan until it's
almost like body temperature.
So you keep doing that.
Let's taste.
LISSA DOUMANI: Yeah, let's.
He's not going to
give me a taste.
OLIVIA: Chefs, what
kind of temperature
are you trying to take this to?
HIRO SONE: Your body
temperature, basically.
OLIVIA: Ok.
Alright.
HIRO SONE: Pretty good.
So can you keep doing this?
LISSA DOUMANI: Yeah,
because I can walk and do--
OLIVIA: It gets expensive
to get her to do that.
LISSA DOUMANI: It's going
to cost you something.
HIRO SONE: Or you can use a fan.
An electric fan.
That's what most
restaurants use.
Just blowing, keep blowing.
LISSA DOUMANI: We don't have
one of those, we have me.
HIRO SONE: Then after
you make the sushi
rice you want to keep it in a
vessel, or something like this.
Or, home, you can keep a cloth
napkin and put the rice here.
And try to keep it warm,
like body temperature.
That's the best, at
that temperature,
You can taste rice really
well at that temperature.
So you can keep warm water
and put a small bowl,
and you can put the lid, and
you can keep the rice that way.
And if the rice
starts getting cold,
change the water to warm it up.
So you can maintain
the temperature.
Can I get some in here?
Let's see.
It's cooled off enough.
OLIVIA: How large a batch
would you make at home, chefs?
HIRO SONE: Home?
We cook maybe
three cups of rice.
LISSA DOUMANI:
Three cups, I think.
I can't remember exactly
what the recipe says,
but it's plenty.
And you don't need
to make all the rice
you cook into sushi rice.
Am I done?
HIRO SONE: Yes, and Chef
Jerome can help you.
Next, I'm going to
show you using tuna
to make three different sushi.
Actually, two different
sushi and one sashimi.
So let's get the tuna over here.
LISSA DOUMANI: So one of the
things in the book that you'll
notice, is that more
than a third of it
is designated to how
to break down fish.
We spent a lot of
time, we argued more
than any two people
are supposed to.
Because if he used turn the
fish 180 degrees, and then
45 degrees to this, and
put the tail on your head,
I was going to hurt him.
Because obviously,
this isn't what
you're going to buy
at a fish store.
But eventually he's going to cut
it to a piece that you can buy.
Now what.
And so, it was important
with every fish
that we show how you
actually clean an octopus,
prepare a squid, do a scallop,
do a whole side of a tuna,
do a sea bass, everything.
So that you could do it at home.
We realize not
everyone's going to.
But it's something
that at least helps
you understand when you're going
to slice the fish, what you're
looking for.
Because you can buy good
fillets of things at markets.
The hard one is the shape
that you want the tuna from.
That you actually have to
go to a Japanese market,
or do it yourself.
HIRO SONE: So, this is
almost a quarter of tuna.
The tail part is missing.
This side has a head,
and this right here
is the belly, and another belly.
Another loin comes here.
So basically, almost
quarter of the fish.
And you see, at the sushi bar,
they call it toro, or chu-toro.
It usually comes from this area.
As you see, the color
is very different.
This is almost red,
and this is pale.
You can see the
color difference.
And big eye tuna has more fat.
Of course bluefin has more
fat here, that's real toro.
This is yellowfin.
And so, it doesn't
have very much fat.
So, I know you don't get
this kind of fish at home,
but basically, let's see.
I'm going to break down this.
LISSA DOUMANI: You
can get this quality.
HIRO SONE: A nice
indication is to take
a look at this
dark part of meat.
It's what we call
bloodline, and usually
if fish gets old it
really becomes black.
That's too old.
You've got the nice
one right here.
It's almost dark pink.
OLIVIA: Chef, does the
blood in the bloodline
actually diffuse into the
flesh if it's too old?
HIRO SONE: Yes it does,
if you keep it too long.
But you can see
this nice dark red.
That's a good sign of
good, nice, fresh fish.
So I'm going to
take-- Let's see.
The sous chef usually keeps out
a section of tuna called saku.
That's a section,
loin, ready to slice.
So usually, the
length is about this.
Some chefs use a finger
to measure the size.
Some chefs use some
kind of things.
But, I usually
cut almost, how do
you say-- How many
inches is that?
LISSA DOUMANI: Six.
HIRO SONE: Six.
Six inches.
LISSA DOUMANI: And you're
also not using a long knife,
you're using a heavier knife.
HIRO SONE: Yeah, because I
had to cut through the skin
and they usually come
off with some scales.
So I wipe it off.
You can see, if we go to
Tsukiji Market in Tokyo,
they use knives with
lengths about this long.
Almost like a samurai sword.
And I'm going to give
this one to Chef Jerome.
So you can use that.
And this one too.
So after this--
LISSA DOUMANI: So
we're still not
to the size you would buy
at the grocery store yet.
HIRO SONE: You can
see some nice fatty
area and the dark red area.
Very lean meat here.
And a lot of people
prefer this area,
because there's more
flavor in the fat.
So I'm going to trim the
bloodline, the dark black spot
first.
LISSA DOUMANI: So
this is something
you would do really slowly.
Really watch where
you're cutting,
because you don't want to
gouge into the part of the meat
that you want.
And you can always go back and
trim just a little bit more.
He's going to have to go
back and get some of this.
So don't think you have to
get it all in the first go.
HIRO SONE: Then you
see the big sinew here,
so I go knife from
here to bottom.
Touch the skin and go up.
Then you get the almost
skin-free loin here.
Then this side.
Again, just slide
the knife slowly.
OLIVIA: Is that
side for me chef?
HIRO SONE: Maybe.
So I left some meat.
This is good for
chopping too, right here.
Very flavorful meat.
Chop and make a hand roll.
LISSA DOUMANI: And if you
don't have that skill,
you could use a
spoon and scrape it.
HIRO SONE: This part
you can eat too, but--
LISSA DOUMANI: That would
be a whole other class.
He's very proud of himself.
He made tuna bloodline
blood sausage the other day.
HIRO SONE: Yeah,
the other day I did.
OLIVIA: Ooh.
AUDIENCE: Yum.
LISSA DOUMANI: And
he used the tuna
fat to make the
little dots in it.
HIRO SONE: So, after
you clean the tuna
you want to change
the cutting board
to a skin or scale-free zone.
So I'm going to get the saku.
LISSA DOUMANI: You
need to explain.
Remember how you decide where
to cut it so that they know.
This is a class.
HIRO SONE: We made a little
piece of paper like this size.
So, how many portions you
can get from the loin.
You can take a look.
Attach the little
piece of paper.
But, you get the idea.
So what I tried to
do is basically,
try to get something like this.
You see this one in the
sushi bar, in the showcase.
That's what you see.
So this is a
technique sushi chef--
because each time tuna
is a different size,
different shape.
But you have to always get
almost the same size saku.
So many experiences give you the
best way to get-- even smaller.
LISSA DOUMANI: The
other thing that we
tried to explain in
writing which was hard,
is that you don't
buy a chunk that big.
You're going to
buy a piece that's
maybe an inch to
two inches in size,
because you're
doing this at home.
This you can see
is a lot of tuna.
Yes, we can probably
eat that, but you
might want to have something
more than just tuna.
So you would buy
a smaller piece.
You may not be able to
do it standing upright,
like he did it.
You might need to
lay it on its side,
but the cutting
process is the same.
So, if you think about how
he cut down from the bottom,
if it's laying down, you
cut across the bottom.
So that you can get
these same pieces.
HIRO SONE: So this one, as you
see, there's a lot of sinew.
And you can test it first.
You can eat without
treating anything.
Or you have to scrape
off meat from sinew.
This is pretty tender so, I'll
go ahead and make another saku
from this.
You can get another
portion from this.
If you taste it's
too sinewy, you're
going to scrape
off with the spoon.
So the technique will be--
LISSA DOUMANI: Is that my job?
HIRO SONE: Yeah.
Lissa can show you.
So take a spoon and gently
scrape off the meat.
LISSA DOUMANI: You're going
just between the sinew.
HIRO SONE: This is
like a sous chef's job.
Chef doesn't do it.
LISSA DOUMANI: Chef has
to wash the dishes though.
HIRO SONE: Oh, why
don't you do this?
LISSA DOUMANI:
Wow, that was mean.
HIRO SONE: So actually,
sushi connoisseurs
prefer this part of
the meat because it's
very flavorful meat.
Just looks a little ugly.
LISSA DOUMANI: Doesn't
look ugly once you
put chopped green
onion and stuff in it.
HIRO SONE: Let me wash my hands.
LISSA DOUMANI: I also
like it because it's
kind of idiot-proof.
OLIVIA: So, how often
are you making sushi
at home for yourselves?
HIRO SONE: Before we made
this book, almost every week
we make sushi.
LISSA DOUMANI: And lately, he's
been getting beautiful tunas,
and half a tuna to Terra.
And so, somehow just a little
bit of the belly comes home.
it's the parts like
this, not those.
But, it's ok.
OLIVIA: So, do people
walk into Terra and say,
would you please, please,
please make me some sushi?
LISSA DOUMANI: They don't
because, we don't have rice.
So we only do sashimi and
crudo and that sort of thing.
We do now do, almost from any
fish we have that we can do it,
we roast the heads.
And we're really surprised at
how many people like the tuna
head.
We'll do a half a tuna head.
It, of course, comes
out this big on a plate.
And there's a few places
there's chunks of meat.
But, people are
really into them.
It's so cool.
Or you've done yellowtail,
you've done hamachi, salmon.
It's really nice.
It's good to see that people
aren't afraid to get--
Do you want this
now or something?
You look very worried.
HIRO SONE: No.
So, I'm going to show you
the fish called tataki.
It's a huge sheet pan.
It's basically seared.
Sashimi preparation,
but it's seared outside.
So you can do it in a saute
pan, with a little oil.
High temperature,
cook quickly, seared.
Or, you can use a torch.
If you have it in the house.
LISSA DOUMANI: Or
if not, go buy one.
They're good for everything.
[BLOW TORCH FIRES]
HIRO SONE: Traditionally,
Japanese people use bonito,
but with the tuna, you can
use this technique too.
LISSA DOUMANI:
And you've noticed
how tataki has entered into the
American cooking terminology.
We tataki New York
steak, we tataki fish.
I think they've
tataki-ed vegetables.
I don't really know what
that means, but I've seen it.
it's now become
common terminology.
Now when were writing the
book, there was always a recipe
that we had a lot
of arguments about.
And this was one of them.
Because Hiro is truly
a purist, and he
wants to teach things from
the very basic of what it is.
So, it's in the book.
We finally said, fine, you can
have your little paragraph.
You have to go out and find
rice hulls, the whole sheath,
and the whole thing
from the rice.
And you have to build a
little fire, and have a grate,
and you put these little
skewers through it,
and that's how you
grill the tataki.
Because somewhere in
Japan that's what they do.
HIRO SONE: So that's a
tradition they did, basically.
LISSA DOUMANI: I don't know
where you buy the rice.
Maybe in Sacramento.
HIRO SONE: So, one
of the dishes we're
going to prepare for you
today is tataki, which
is seared, almost
seared, sashimi plate.
So beautiful.
The inside is bright red and
it has a thin, white rim.
And also, searing
the skin, and it
sits on a sauce called ponzu,
it absorbs ponzu really well.
And it stays on this
dry area, cooked area.
So that helps.
Instead of the sauce
slipping off from tuna,
it's going to stay on the skin.
LISSA DOUMANI: It holds it.
I get an answer margarita
today, for this.
HIRO SONE: This is lemon,
just thinly sliced lemon.
Going to put it on the
bottom of the bowl,
and the three slices of tataki.
And this is wasabi leaf.
Everybody know wasabi?
It looks like this.
Just like a horseradish,
a Japanese horseradish.
It grows in a clean stream.
So, Olivia picked it up
for us from Half Moon Bay,
it comes from Half Moon Bay.
LISSA DOUMANI: That was the
one thing we got to teach her,
because she really
knows everything.
But she didn't know there
was wasabi in Half Moon Bay.
HIRO SONE: We're going to
make a little julienne.
So just roll the
wasabi leaf and cut.
OLIVIA: So chef, how important
is it to have a sharp knife
to cut raw fish with at home?
HIRO SONE: Also, a sharp
knife really helps.
Usually, if you have a dull
knife, you cut yourself too.
Because you force it.
If you have a sharp
knife it's easy
because, the weight
of the knife really
cuts everything,
instead of forcing.
So, it really helps.
And also, for
sashimi, you can see
how shiny the surface
of the sashimi.
Maybe if have a
dull knife, you're
basically breaking
each cell of flesh.
Almost sometimes
with a sharp knife,
you cut yourself and
you don't feel it.
LISSA DOUMANI: Yes,
I can attest to that.
HIRO SONE: Then ten
minutes later, oh shit.
Excuse me.
LISSA DOUMANI: No cussing.
HIRO SONE: Please cut there.
[LAUGHTER]
LISSA DOUMANI: You've got
to put a dollar in the bowl.
HIRO SONE: Anyway, so
this is ponzu source.
Also in our book.
Basically, Japanese
soy citrus mix.
LISSA DOUMANI: And, I'm assuming
that almost everyone knows
ponzu.
But, ponzu is one of
the master sauces,
you put it with a
little bit of olive oil,
you have the
greatest vinaigrette.
You put it with
mayonnaise, and you'll
have the greatest other sauce.
It just goes with everything.
HIRO SONE: So I
put a little wasabi
on the top, wasabi
leaf on the top.
So, this is one of the dishes
you're going to taste today.
The next thing I'm going to
prepare, nigiri with the tuna.
LISSA DOUMANI: Should
I steal your tuna
so it could get wrapped up?
You want to move over to here?
HIRO SONE: Yes.
LISSA DOUMANI: I cleaned.
Probably not well enough.
You need all of those?
HIRO SONE: No.
OLIVIA: So, you want to tell
us about the restaurant you're
going to open soon?
LISSA DOUMANI: Soon.
August 1st.
I'm determined.
I'm a very determined girl.
We took over, I
think a lot of you
might know the old
original Slanted
Door on Valencia
between 16th and 17th.
So we took that over.
Charles is our
landlord and luckily
our friend, which is probably
a good bad thing, who knows.
It's a great space.
It's very narrow and long.
And we're going to open
a modern bistro there,
and its name is
going to be Urchin.
One, because I really can't
eat ever too much sea urchin.
HIRO SONE: She loves sea urchin.
LISSA DOUMANI: Yeah, it's
a little frightening.
HIRO SONE: It's a funny story.
After we got
married in Japan, we
went to visit Kyoto and we were
just walking around the hotel--
LISSA DOUMANI: We were
looking for cold medicine.
HIRO SONE: That's right.
And we found a
little fish market.
And we went in there, they're
serving fish inside the market
too.
So, we sit down and there's
an old, old gentleman.
He's drinking sake.
And something arrived
on the front of him.
It was a whole tray
of uni, sea urchin.
He was just eating
uni and drinking sake,
and eat uni and drinking sake.
LISSA DOUMANI: Sumimasen.
HIRO SONE: Lissa said,
can I have one of those.
Yes, she finished
the whole tray too.
LISSA DOUMANI: We just
did it again, actually.
We went with some friends.
We didn't take them, but we
kind of took them, to Japan
in November-- writers
and restaurateur friends.
And we went to the fish
market their, Tsukiji.
And you can buy stuff there.
The people don't know that,
but they'll sell it to you.
You don't have to
be a restaurant.
They will growl at
you quite a bit,
and try and run you
down with the carts.
That's another issue.
But, I bought a whole
tray of uni again.
And they always have some hashi,
some chopsticks, someplace.
And so, we all sat
like in a little corner
eating our uni that had just
freshly come from Hokkaido.
It was beautiful.
HIRO SONE: So, I'm going to
show you how to make nigiri.
First, we need to
grate the wasabi.
LISSA DOUMANI:
Ooh, I can do that.
HIRO SONE: Grater like this.
So, circular movement like this.
LISSA DOUMANI: And, you
can get fresh wasabi now.
We'll see it in
Japanese markets.
I don't see it in Western
markets, but in Asian markets
you'll see it.
It's a little pricey, but it
does keep for a little while.
Yeah pretty much don't
have to do it now.
HIRO SONE: What's that?
LISSA DOUMANI: No, I
don't have to do it.
[LAUGHTER]
HIRO SONE: And the next one
we need is a kind of water,
because the rice is sticky.
So, this prevents the rice
from sticking on your finger.
Mix with water and vinegar.
LISSA DOUMANI: Just a
tiny bit of vinegar.
It's just so that
you're seasoned.
HIRO SONE: And cutting fish.
Basically, you like
to keep it-- the rice
ball is going to
be about this size.
So, you want to drape over
so it's a little longer
than the rice ball.
And the rice ball
will be this big.
So, a little bit bigger
than the rice ball.
So basically.
LISSA DOUMANI: So, how
are you determining
which angle to cut at?
HIRO SONE: So,
that's another thing.
If you cut this way, you
don't get enough length. , So,
depending on what
you've got here,
you need to change the
angle to get what you need.
And this way changes
the width of the loin.
LISSA DOUMANI: So, I
think you've probably
seen that in sushi bars.
The chef will put down a
piece, especially of tuna,
but other fish.
And he'll move it, turn it
over, go back and forth,
because he's looking for the
way he can get the size piece he
wants, and he's also
watching the grain
that he's going to be cutting.
More important on these.
HIRO SONE: And then, some chefs
make some really long fish.
Some sushi bars make it tiny.
LISSA DOUMANI: We don't
like to go to that one.
But, on the other
hand, we don't like
the one that's an inch
over on either side, so
something in between.
Because this is a rule in
sushi, but I don't abide by it,
and have gotten
yelled at by Morimoto.
I don't eat sushi in one bite.
I don't care what you
do I'm not going to.
I always want that second bite.
But when they make
them really long,
it's hard because,
truthfully you're
supposed to put it all
in your mouth at once.
And the guys that make
these really long ones,
I don't really know
how you do that you
look like a Chipmunk,
or something.
Putting that much food,
little cheeks are bulging.
But you are supposed
to eat it in one bite.
HIRO SONE: Moisten your
hand with, we call it tezu.
Te, means hand.
Zu, tsu, is vinegar.
And take sushi
rice, and I usually
get about 20 grams of rice.
Which is like this size.
So, in this hand you
make a ball already.
In the same time, the sushi
chef takes a piece of fish
and uses this finger to get
some wasabi onto the fish.
LISSA DOUMANI: That's a lot.
HIRO SONE: That's a
lot of wasabi, yes.
LISSA DOUMANI: Well, it
came with its own string.
Because somebody
may eat that later.
HIRO SONE: What's that?
LISSA DOUMANI: Somebody
may eat that later.
We didn't want to
have the string.
HIRO SONE: So, I'll make
a ball and put it on here.
Then press with left hand thumb.
And there's another
way to do it.
Some chefs just
roll it this way.
And some chefs take two
hands to put it back here.
LISSA DOUMANI: Which is the
way that we describe it.
HIRO SONE: There's two ways.
Then you bend your finger
like this to make a cup,
and gently push.
At the same time, this
thumb holds the other side.
Push, and 180 degree
twist, and push again.
And hold both sides gently,
and again, calm gently.
Then nigiri.
LISSA DOUMANI: Nice.
HIRO SONE: Pretty good?
LISSA DOUMANI: Yeah.
See, it's important
to note he is not,
and I'm obviously
not, sushi chefs.
That's not what we cook.
And it was an important
part of doing the book,
because if you
really do this you're
going to write something
that's, you forget to add things
that people don't know.
And so, this was really
intricately written.
He'd describe something
and I'm saying
you can't say that because
it doesn't make sense.
And so, we try to make it so
that it was understandable.
HIRO SONE: Another way is
just make a ball in your hand,
and you put it on
the cutting board
and gently press down
to something like this.
LISSA DOUMANI: It's not
as fussy as it seems.
That's the best thing
you can learn from it.
HIRO SONE: Then the same
idea with the wasabi,
and just drape over
in the form like this.
This will be maybe
much, much easier.
But at the sushi bar,
they don't do that.
Doesn't look good,
the sushi chef
making everything like that.
Some chefs move
their hand like this.
It's not necessary, but it looks
like the fish is still alive.
They do like this.
Because, it's
almost like a show.
LISSA DOUMANI: Hey,
let's do this one.
HIRO SONE: In another way,
Lissa is going to show you,
is to put the fish
on the plastic.
And put the wasabi here,
in the little bowl.
LISSA DOUMANI: And
this has its own name.
HIRO SONE: You can put shrimp.
LISSA DOUMANI: No,
what's it called?
HIRO SONE: Oh, temari-zushi.
It's almost like
making a rice ball.
LISSA DOUMANI: You're
making beach balls.
HIRO SONE: Let me get
the rice off of my hand.
So, just gently fold
it and twist it.
LISSA DOUMANI: So this
really couldn't be easier.
HIRO SONE: Now, this is a
really easy way to do it,
and kind of cute.
And you can make it
different colors,
and even put a little
caviar under there.
And you can make it
ahead like this already,
and when everybody comes
just open up and plate it.
It's very cute.
LISSA DOUMANI: This we
don't talk about very
much in the book, but
it is another style.
OK, now you gotta roll baby.
HIRO SONE: And,
I have a garnish.
This is serrano chili,
marinated in soy sauce,
if you like it spicy.
And this is the same
serrano chili but,
using a torch to make
a charred flavor.
LISSA DOUMANI: Or a broiler.
HIRO SONE: That's also good.
LISSA DOUMANI: And
a toaster oven.
We
HIRO SONE: And maybe
this needs this guy.
And this is ginger.
We call it gari, it's
pickled ginger, young ginger.
It's a palate cleanser.
So, between when you
eat different sushi.
LISSA DOUMANI: Yeah,
it's not a salad.
It's a palate cleanser.
We also have a whole thing
about sushi etiquette, which
there is etiquette to sushi.
It doesn't mean you
have to live by it,
but I think it's nice
if everybody knows it.
Which is, one, that's a palate
cleanser, it's not a salad.
Another is that you dip
the sushi fish-side down
in the soy sauce,
not the other way.
If the chef has seasoned it,
you don't need to do anything.
And they'll usually tell you.
I don't know that
we're always listening.
Because sometimes
I even have to say,
am I supposed to dip this one,
because I didn't pay attention.
Then usually, the wasabi is
in there, how much you want.
How much he wants, but
it's okay to add more.
But you don't put
it in the soy sauce.
HIRO SONE: So I'm
chopping, using
the back side of the knife
[CHOPPING] for hand roll.
So, tuna like this, and
take some mayonnaise.
Japanese people like mayonnaise.
LISSA DOUMANI: They
like Kewpie Mayonnaise.
HIRO SONE: They like it so much.
Even they made their own brand
called Kewpie Mayonnaise.
I've got tobiko in there, a
little bit of green onion,
sesame seeds, and
most important,
sriracha, if you like spicy.
LISSA DOUMANI: At least he
gets to stay in California.
HIRO SONE: And mix together.
Like this.
And they usually come in
this size, for the hand roll,
we need half.
So Lissa is cutting.
Just before you use nori, just
lightly toast on your burner.
Turn if off, and just
go, this is the burner,
just go like this.
Then it becomes much,
much more flavorful.
And you can smell the
nori that way too.
LISSA DOUMANI: It makes
it a little crisper too.
You can also buy this,
it's kind of silly,
but you can buy it
this shape already.
HIRO SONE: Oh, yeah?
LISSA DOUMANI: Yeah.
HIRO SONE: Yeah, I guess.
LISSA DOUMANI: He
doesn't grocery shop.
HIRO SONE: So, this is a
little bigger, about this big.
So put it in here.
So you can use half the
nori space you have, spread.
And make a little
dent in the middle,
for the place the fish is going.
Oops.
LISSA DOUMANI: Oops isn't good.
HIRO SONE: So, here's the fish.
Lissa, would you cut
me the daikon sprouts?
Was it here?
LISSA DOUMANI:
Yeah, I've got them.
HIRO SONE: So, it
goes in the middle.
So, you want to keep
everything, this
is going to be the
peak of the cone.
So everything in this angle.
So, we're going to roll.
Just a little bit.
So this we can put here.
A little more.
So start rolling from this end.
This is going to
meet in the middle,
like this, and keep rolling.
Then you get the hand roll.
LISSA DOUMANI:
So, a lot of times
when you're trying to do this
your mind plays tricks on you
and you end up with,
actually, a roll this way.
Because you just
kind of want to go
like that, instead of
keeping it in a v-shape.
So, just be conscious
while you're rolling,
because you just have to
pay attention, is all.
It's not hard certainly.
HIRO SONE: So, these
three dishes today.
OLIVIA: Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
OLIVIA: Thank you.
It's delicious.
And while our chefs are
preparing tastes for you,
are there questions
for Lissa and Hiro?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are there
knives that you
would recommend
in terms of sushi?
OLIVIA: What knives
would you recommend?
LISSA DOUMANI: There's a
huge price point difference.
And so, there are great Japanese
knives that are available here.
I think that if you
want to buy something
that's reasonable
that's available.
Mac is a good
company, Mac knives.
Do you know which ones are,
she's asking about knives.
And so, I know that I'll
use Mac quite a bit.
It's a Japanese knife, and
they're a little heartier.
HIRO SONE: I use a Japanese
knife called Masamoto.
LISSA DOUMANI: Yes, which
you can't really get here.
HIRO SONE: No, you can get it.
LISSA DOUMANI: Soko Hardware.
Thank gosh.
So, I don't know that
they have that one.
But the problem with
true Japanese knives
is the care of them,
and so, you have
to be ready to care
for them that way.
They need a different
way of sharpening.
HIRO SONE: As you
see, I cut the lemon,
and it started changing color.
Because this is
steel, not stainless.
This is stainless, looks
like a Japanese knife
but made with stainless.
LISSA DOUMANI: And
who made that one?
HIRO SONE: This
one is Shun knife.
I didn't buy this one.
They gave it to me so, I
don't know how much it was.
LISSA DOUMANI:
You're just spoiled.
OLIVIA: There are a
couple of other stores
with Japanese knives
maybe not to your level.
There's the Perfect
Edge in San Mateo.
And Japan Woodworker is an
online store in Alameda.
LISSA DOUMANI: There's
a couple knives
that you really
want to have too.
You want something that's strong
enough to, like he was using,
that's a little heavier
and strong enough to cut.
Depending on the fish, you want
a really good slicing knife.
Either one of these.
HIRO SONE: The basic
difference in a Western knife
and Japanese knife
is, you can see it.
One side is flat, one side
is angled and goes this way.
LISSA DOUMANI: They're
sharp on one side.
HIRO SONE: Western style is
both coming together like this.
It's easier to use it,
you have more control.
This one, you have
to get used it,
because if you use
a Western knife
it usually goes-- Because
of the angle of the blade.
So, you have to be careful.
You have to practice
a little bit.
Almost straight cutting, but you
have a feeling over your hand.
The force is this way,
eventually goes straight.
So, that part is
really different.
And sashimi, the
very important part
is that this angle makes
the fish not stick.
Because the angle is different.
So, that's a good
part of this knife.
As you see, one side
is flat, one side--
So left hand and
right hand knife.
This one, it's always the same.
LISSA DOUMANI:
Sharp on both sides.
HIRO SONE: This one, you need
to buy one for left-hander,
one for the right-hander.
OLIVIA: Any other questions?
Yeah.
LISSA DOUMANI: How much
was the side of tuna?
OLIVIA: How much was that?
10 pound?
Price.
HIRO SONE: Usually like $16
a pound at the restaurant,
we pay.
$16 to anywhere about $45.
LISSA DOUMANI: Some
sushi bars, of course,
they buy whole fish quite often.
And really good ones
buy the fish and age it,
because there's a misnomer about
fresh fish being the best fish.
Quite often, most
fish needs to be
aged a little bit
before you eat it.
And they'll have tuna
vaults, the place
that they keep them, they know
what day they were brought in,
they rotate, and
move them around.
There are few places that do
that in the city, not a lot.
Or they have a fish
purveyor do it for them.
And then there's
different pricing depends
on the quality of the fish,
the fatiness in the fish.
Watch something about
the fish market in Tokyo.
It's just amazing
watching them do this.
I've done this and I don't
know what they're doing.
We went to the one, both
in Japan and Hawaii,
and they take something
and they're doing this.
And I'm like,
yeah, that's yucky.
But, they know.
HIRO SONE: Yeah, sometimes
the fish is too fresh
and the meat is, how
do you call that?
After it dies?
Rig--
LISSA DOUMANI: Rigor mortis.
OLIVIA: Rigor mortis.
HIRO SONE: So, the
meat is so tight.
LISSA DOUMANI: Tense.
HIRO SONE: And you slice it and
even when you put it in mouth,
it's still kind of hard.
So you need to wait a
period to make good sashimi.
Also, protein breaks
down to amino acid.
Gives you more umami too.
OLIVIA: Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Where
in the South Bay,
can you get all this fresh fish?
OLIVIA: Where in the South
Bay to get fresh fish?
Yes.
LISSA DOUMANI: There's a
couple of Japanese markets
in San Jose.
HIRO SONE: If you go
to the Japanese market,
you already find the tuna made
into saku, like this already.
Couple of different fish,
hamachi, or something.
You can buy it
looking like this.
LISSA DOUMANI: Yeah,
already block cut.
We should have done our
research and looked that up,
but we do know that Nijiya
has a market down there.
I know that.
I think they have a market
somewhere near Mountain View
too.
OLIVIA: There's a
lot in San Mateo.
LISSA DOUMANI: So, it's
just, it's not our hood.
OLIVIA: Not their hood.
LISSA DOUMANI: We've
got Napa and parts
of San Francisco and
maybe Little East Bay,
but that's about it.
But, because we know where
they're available to us,
even in Napa, there's
a couple places
you could buy good
fish for this.
I'm sure you guys have
a lot, because there's
a larger community for it.
HIRO SONE: And also,
our book features
a lot of different
vegetables, vegetarian sushi.
I think that's a
new thing to me.
Fish regulations are harder
and harder every year,
so even back there, you
have vegetables, make sushi.
OLIVIA: Yeah, very nice.
LISSA DOUMANI: So, this
one here, tuna, red pepper,
cool, huh?
OLIVIA: It's beautiful.
LISSA DOUMANI: The
other one is eggplant.
Looks a little bit like anago.
So, one looks like eel
and one looks like tuna.
We're not trying to
say it's not something
that it isn't but it's
cool how it can trick you.
OLIVIA: Thank you so much.
HIRO SONE: Thank you.
LISSA DOUMANI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]